[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand invité des territoires on savait
les élèves peu à peu ont repris le
chemin de l'école le banc des classes
c'est donc pour les cp les cm2 lait
maternel
en attendant un retour total à la
normale va se rendre maintenant en
savoie vous allez voir au 28 écoles ont
ouvert leurs portes
voici ce qui s'est passé cette semaine
avec ce reportage tourné par les équipes
de 8 mont blanc à l'école jacob
bellecombette du côté du bassin
chambérien regarder le plus dur c'est
vraiment pas pouvoir partager les jeux
d'être en tout cas pour les petites
sections d'être à leur place toute la
journée au même endroit c'est ça qui est
difficile
seuls les enfants de soignants et
d'enseignants peuvent être accueillis
pour le moment les classes et salle de
repos les sanitaires ont été aménagés
par les équipes les groupes les classes
le matériel spécifique à chaque enfant
donc tout a été personnalisé chaque
enfant tout le matériel qui ne lit est
utile pour la journée et pour toute la
journée en vue les jeux qui sont veut
collectifs sont mis en quarantaine pour
qu'il n'ait à utiliser le lundi soir
utilisé lundi sur de l'autre côté de la
rue l'élémentaire aussi reprend vie face
à la crise la créativité des couleurs
des cheminements des espacements pour
enseigner ici à 32 élèves près d'un
quart de l'effectif habituel l'école de
jacob bellecombette est l'une des
premières à se remettre en marche la
plupart en savoie ouvriront jeudi où la
semaine prochaine dans cette école ici à
jacob bellecombette on a plutôt des
demandes fortes de la part des parents
et on n'a même pas pu accueillir tous
ceux qui souhaitaient que leurs enfants
soient scolarisés
donc pour l'instant je pense qu'un
certain nombre de parents sont en
période d'observation mais je m'attends
à ce que d'ici quelques quelques jours
quelques semaines on est à une
augmentation du nombre de demandes et
nous essaierons si possible de maintenir
les conditions actuelles pendant les
trois semaines du mois de mai et on
verra fin mais comment on peut augmenter
et faire évoluer les organisations je
crois que c'est notre rôle
donc je veux je pense que c est normal
de le faire
et puis c'est peut-être aussi pour nous
nous mettre un petit peu dans le dans le
banc pour le mois de septembre puisque
nous ne savons pas non plus ce qui va se
passer en septembre
donc c'est peut-être pas mal non plus de
faire un premier pas sans attendre le
mois de septembre en savoie
95% des écoles ont rouvert leurs portes
aux enfants et enseignants ce mardi ou
dans les tout prochains jours et vous le
savez les masques sont désormais
obligatoires dans les métros les trains
et les bus les règles des transports
publics ont dû s'adapter à toutes ces
nouvelles réglementations
comment réagit-on du côté des usagers
regardez ce reportage de damien deparnay
notre confrère de la chaîne away ou dans
les hauts de france en ce premier jour
de déconfinement et bien la situation
est très calme sur le réseau de
transport en commun on est ici à la
station de métro gare lille flandres qui
est normalement très fréquentée puis
vous le voyez bien cette station est
quasiment vide en ce lundi matin
seulement cent mille passagers ont été
comptabilisés en moyenne ce matin contre
les 750 mille passagers à habituel des
passagers qui pour la très très grande
majorité ont bel et bien leur masque qui
est désormais obligatoire pour pénétrer
dans les stations de métro lilloise
il y a beaucoup d'agents indiqué via qui
ont été déployés 300 agents sur
l'ensemble du réseau qui sont là pour
informer les usagers sur évidemment le
port du masque mais également sur les
règles de distanciation social à
respecter pour cela et bien ce sont des
milliers d'autocollants comme ceci tous
responsables gardons nos distances des
milliers d'autocollants qui ont donc été
déposés dans l'ensemble des stations à
l'intérieur des rames également pour
faire respecter les distanciation
sociale également 1
tu es l'installation de distributeurs
automatiques de solutions hydro
alcooliques à l'entrée des stations
les masques sont bien entendu devenu
indispensable dans notre quotidien
mais est ce que nous en aurons
suffisamment c'est la question que tout
le monde se pose depuis des semaines
vous savez que les collectivités locales
font tout pour en commander la plupart
du temps ils le font en chine alors en
duplex avec nous à mettre carabasse
bonjour à mettre carabasse vous fait
depuis dix ans est français du sourcing
en chine du trading aussi vous aider
vous faciliter le commerce entre la
france et la chine
alors pourquoi m avons nous tant attendu
ces masques en provenance de chine est
fabriqué en chine des gens dans un
premier temps je pense que là il ya une
prise de conscience a fait part devant
de multiples que des masques en france
pour enrayer le
justement là
le virus j'ai envie de dire le fait que
tous les pays et toutes les commandes
sont arrivées en même temps en chine
vous imaginez en dehors 80% des pays qui
devait avoir besoin de justement de ces
masses quoi il aurait après avoir
probablement de demande qui étaient
énormes en fête est donc là c'était
vraiment le premier cri arrivé le
premier qui était servi à mettre
qu'abbas vous êtes installés en chine
en fait du trading du sourcing là bas
depuis 10 ans est ce que les chinois ont
profiter commercialement de cette ruée
sur les masques alors j'ai pas j'ai pas
envie de dire que des jumeaux profiter
de vos stars mais je pense que c'est
tout un emballement parce que tout tout
tout aille jouer en faveur de la hausse
des prix c'est la demande qui est énorme
par rapport à l'offre
c'est juste ça qui a fait que les prix
augmenter parce que tout a monté d'un
coup c'est pas le louvier chinois que
leur campus où l'électricité en chine
etc ou la mersey la machine c'est les
matières premières c'est le transport
parce que le transport aujourd'hui le 30
ans du cargo il est à peu près 1 4 5
fois le prix peuvent rapport aux
périodes normales et l'a d'ailleurs
avoue jour d'aujourd'hui je vous parle
on s'aperçoit que la demande a baissé
parce que quasiment et beaucoup de
commandes ont déjà été passées là on est
on est en effet nous ment il est pris
déjà commencent à baisser de 20 à 30%
déjà dès maintenant un maître qu'abbas
vous avez 36 ans
comment vivent les jeunes chinois de
votre génération se ce virus ce nouveau
virus qui est arrivé dans leur vie moi
je pense que bon ils ont déjà un peu
l'expérience parce que il ya déjà eu des
cas de farce et cetera au début des
années 2000 a encore dans le bandeau
donc ils ont déjà fermé là aujourd'hui
le fixe que que ce virus
pour n'augmenter je pense que lui aussi
soit un peu surpris t'as pas encore trop
comment ça va évoluer mais ils sont sûrs
d'une chose c'est que demain ou dans un
mois ou dans six mois leur vie ne va pas
être là même qui était avant cette crise
est sur quelque chose qui va changer
c'est qu'il va changer profondément
beaucoup de choses mais dont beaucoup
d'interrogations merci à m car base
d'avoir été notre invité en duplex vous
vivez en chine depuis dix ans mais sur
une vidéo voilà m regardez ce reportage
il va sans doute vous intéresser même si
ce n'est pas de la science fiction elle
pourrait être sortie d'un film ce sont
des caméras thermiques qui détecte à
distance la température du corps humain
sur le modèle de ce qui se fait en chine
dans certaines entreprises depuis début
mars
leur objectif est bien ce sont
d'identifier les personnes dont la
température corporelle dépasse les 38
degrés l'un des symptômes marqueur du
coc vie de 19 pour les médecins une
innovation qui commencera aussi
intéresser les collectivités locales en
cette période de déconfinement égalise
pour vient mirabel a poussé les portes
d'une entreprise messine qui proposent
ce genre de produits
regardez ce reportage imaginons je viens
avec une source de chaleur la
température détecter les cas de fièvre
jusqu'à cinq mètres de distance et en
moins d'une seconde c'est le rôle de ces
caméra thermique une technologie déjà
utilisée en chine qui fait son entrée
sur le marché français dès le début de
la crise sanitaire cette société messine
est spécialisée dans la sécurité adapte
son activité elle est alors l'une des
premières à tester et commercialiser ce
genre de produits d'habitude on installe
des systèmes de sécurité électronique de
la vidéo surveillance du contrôle
d'accès et de la détection intrusion
évidemment dès le début du confinement
tous nos chantiers se son arrêt se sont
arrêtés ça a été un petit peu difficile
pour notre entreprise et le fait qu'on
puisse proposer à nos clients ces
caméras thermiques de détection de
fièvre ça a été une grande bouffée
d'oxygène
si on n'avait pas fait ça
notre chiffre d'affaires installations a
été 0 en mars avril et peut être même en
deux mois la société vend près de
soixante bornes de caméras thermiques la
grande distribution les sites
logistiques et industrielles mais aussi
les chantiers du btp dont les activités
ont dû continuer au plus fort de la
pandémie ont été les premiers acheteurs
par rapport à un thermomètre frontale
classique on respecte à 100% la
distanciation sociale c'est très rapide
puisque on est dans un flux vidéo
continue continue et on a une grande
précision de ce capteur aussi de l'ordre
de 0.5 de 5° en cas de fièvre
charge ensuite à chaque entreprise de
dicter ses règles et un autre modèle
peut aussi détecter le port de masques
et même être directement relié un
portique de filtrage des accès on a vu
au niveau national des villes qui ont
installé les caméras pour détecter le
port de masques
nous on a proposé dès la semaine
dernière à la ville de reims d'installer
des caméras thermiques sur les centres
de distribution de masques
conformément à la réglementation ces
caméras nos registres aucune donnée mais
le système a ses limites puisqu'il ne
détectent pas les malades
asymptomatiques
il ne peut donc en aucun cas remplacer
les campagnes de dépistage voilà vous
faites peut-être partie de celles et de
ceux qui ont dû se ruer dans les salons
de coiffure depuis le déconfit nages
vous savez qu'ils affichent presque tous
complets il a fallu pour eux d'ailleurs
faire preuve d'anticipation et surtout
respecter les gestes barrière
l'expérience a été menée par les équipes
devient vosges
regardez
oui ben j'étais le premier ce matin et
puis m'ont plu tout de suite premier
jour de déconfinement tant attendue les
coiffeurs ont repris leurs ciseaux pour
le plus grand plaisir de leurs clients
dans ce salon de coiffure à saint dié
des vosges dès l'ouverture il y avait
déjà du monde ici normalement c'est sans
rendez vous mais en ce moment l'agenda
est bien rempli et pour gérer cette
forte demande sans se couper les cheveux
en quatre
il a fallu s'organiser on sentait qu'il
y avait une grosse une forte demande et
qu'on allaite très sollicité on peut
prendre rendez vous soit par téléphone
soit via un site internet qui existait
déjà mais qu'on utilisait très peu donc
du coup il va falloir que les gens aussi
changent leurs habitudes au moins
jusqu'à ce que tout ça se termine
deux mois sans coiffeur pour certains
clients c'en était trop il était temps
de venir au salon avant de commettre
l'irréparable
et ça m'a beaucoup gêné parce que j'ai
les cheveux coupés court normalement
donc la france je branche les recouper
un peu moi même mais pour le reste je me
suis pas senti qu compétente pour le
faire échouer
seulement l'ombre je suis toujours
habitué à me coiffer les cheveux très
courts
équipé de la tête aux pieds les
professionnels l'ap et coiffes des
cheveux avec un masque et parfois des
lunettes
dans cet autre salon de coiffure à
epinal 2 sièges sur neuf ont été
condamnés pour respecter toutes les
mesures barrières on a les désinfectants
pour tout ce qui est matériel les
espèces de coiffage etc
les gels hydroalcooliques et en plus
j'ai fait mais des dépressifs de
protection entre les fauteuils ce qui
rassure les clients
on le savait qu'on devait venir avec un
masque pour respecter la distance de
sécurité
oui pour le savez que ça on sent
effectivement que tout est respecté il
n'y a pas de la part de risque on peut
venir ici en confiance et effectivement
je pense que tous les commerçants vont
respecter toutes ces mesures avec cet
afflux de clients pour ces prochaines
semaines la gérante ouvrira son salon
jusqu'à 21h deux fois par semaine et a
même embauché une nouvelle coiffeuse à
temps partiel voilà il ya aussi des
bonnes nouvelles dans certains
départements vous le savez les plages
vont pouvoir ouvrir
on va se rendre maintenant en bretagne
dans le morbihan par contre où l'accès
est toujours interdite et cette
situation devrait perdurer quelques
jours encore les maires des communes
littorales et le préfet devrait
rapidement prendre des dérogations pour
la population karine chevrollier pour la
chaîne tébéo
sur place nous le raconte trois options
possibles pour les maires du littoral
morbihannais un accès aux plages pour
les activités nautiques et ajouter les
activités physiques ou encore les
activités sédentaires la grande majorité
se positionne sur l'option 2 mais la
physionomie d'une plage va déterminer
les demandes de dérogations ont variera
entre la catégorie 1 la plage qui sert
d'accès aux activités nautiques et la
catégorie 2 qui est la plage celle que
je défends des la plage dynamique c'est
celle où on se déplace on fait du sport
on fait de la pêche à pied etc etc et
qui aussi peut correspondre un littoral
breton pour d'autres pas question de
permettre les activités sportives à
carnac
le maire envisage de mettre en place
seulement deux points d'accès nautique
la grande classe de carnac le week-end
de la pentecôte s'est pas uni des
personnes sur la plage c'est 25000 vous
fais comment pour respecter ce que me
demande le préfet la garantie
distanciation physique c'est si terrible
que ça peut attendre 15 jours pour avoir
accès aux plages
est-ce que ça en vaut la chandelle par
rapport aux risques qu'on en cours si on
se plante
si on se plante chaire confinement les
priorités sont avant tout sanitaires
mais aussi environnemental un retour en
masse sur les plages pourraient être
catastrophiques pour la faune mais
l'aspect économique autour de la
réouverture des plages joue une place
essentielle
on sait très bien qu'on peut pas laisser
la situation figée comme elle est et
qu'il faudra bien redémarré donc il ya
aussi cette volonté de deux participé au
rebond économique de nos territoires et
à
moi cette vie progressivement normal
qu'on pourrait retrouver à condition
d'être prudent de pennetta guidel le
morbihan compte 63 communes littorales
d'ici la fin de semaine chaque commune
devrait formuler sa demande auprès du
préfet si elles le souhaitent pour un
accès plus libre aux plages il faudra
patienter à minima jusqu'au 2 juin
nous nous rendons à dolancourt où le
parc d'attractions nigloland ouvre
progressivement normalement ses portes
au public à partir du mois d'avril en
raison de la crise
elles sont logiquement fermé et les
allées entièrement vidés de leurs
visiteurs dans l'attenté d'une décision
gouvernementale le parc met tout en
oeuvre afin d'accueillir le public dès
que possible
le point complet avec nos confrères de
canal 32 sur place
malgré la fermeture nigloland se prépare
à accueillir le public dès que possible
pour le directeur d'exploitation du
cinquième parc d'attractions français en
terme de fréquentation ce mois de mai
est insolite
normalement il ya du monde dans le parc
y rentrer surtout à cette heure là on
est sur les ponts mais donc cédé des
pics de fréquentation il ya quelques
milliers de visiteurs qui est qu'ils
rentrent dans par classe c'est différent
ça fait 30 ans que ça n'est jamais
arrivé
nigloland accueille plus de six cent
mille visiteurs par an dès les annonces
du confinement
la direction n'a imaginé trois scénarios
pour la saison 2009 1 sa préférence
réouverture en juillet en septembre ou
bien rester fermés ne pas ouvrir ses
ports visage abl parce qu'économiquement
ce n'est pas viable
c'est difficile ouvrir en septembre ça
fait vraiment une période très courte
donc il faut embaucher et former du
personnel pour très peu jours
d'ouverture est ce que ça vaut le coup
on se pose la question et une ouverture
en juillet on sait qu'il ya quelques
millions de français qui n'iront pas à
l'étranger cette année
du coup ça nous laisse beaucoup d'espoir
les recommandations gouvernementales
pour le secteur du tourisme seront
débattus mi mai et annoncé début juin
quoi qu'il arrive six salariés
s'affairent on continue à l'entretien
des quarante trois acteurs du parc ou
six ans absente pendant un mois et demi
deux mois on est au printemps on est en
pleine pousse de gazon on va revenir nos
gazons il
à cinquante centimètres de haut et sont
inesthétiques et on va mettre du temps à
les récupérer
après il ya tout les jeunes plantations
on a fait cet hiver et à l'automne si on
les arrose pas avec le mois dernier on a
eu des grosses chaleurs on va avoir
beaucoup de pertes
l'état d'esprit c'est on maintient le
parc dans le meilleur état possible de
manière que si on a la chance de pouvoir
ouvrir rapidement et ben pas du jour au
lendemain mais très rapidement soit
capable de dire bah nous tous les feux
sont au vert
on peut y aller actuellement on est en
train de finir la nouveauté 2020 deux
mots cet express qui est derrière moi et
nous avons également commencé les
travaux
la nouveauté 2021 donc qu'ovide 19 au
jeu ou non ni de l'onda a choisi de
continuer à investir
nigloland prépare son plan de sécurité
sanitaire et définit les mesures de
prévention contre le coc vie 19 à partir
de cette semaine les personnels vont
installer des distributeurs de gel
hydroalcoolique davantage de points pour
se laver les mains et des marquages de
distanciation
si le parc pourrait être autorisé à
accueillir plus de 5000 personnes
simultanées ce plan doit définir de
propositions de seuil
combien de personnes on pourrait
accueillir sur le parking dans le parc
dans les files d'attentes
parce qu'il faut pas que les gens soient
non plus tous serrés les uns contre les
autres il faut il ya quand même une
logique à respecter donc on est en cours
d'étude c'est assez c'est assez complexe
pour m pour l'instant il n'y a pas
d'obligation qu'on va recommander aux
visiteurs de venir avec des masques peut
pas les obliger le masque idée
peut-être aujourd'hui anxiogène mais
dans quelques jours quand tout le monde
sera dé confiné qu'on aura l'habitude de
vivre avec
on va s'y faire je pense à passer mon
avis personnel ça va vraiment faire du
bien je pense que la réouverture des
parcs des espaces de loisirs des plages
ça va faire ça fait des mois qu'on
attend ça si l'ouverture mi juillet est
autorisée rodolphe g10 espère accueillir
près de quatre cent mille visiteurs
jusqu'à novembre
voilà certains l'attendaient depuis très
longtemps le déconfinement va permettre
aux amoureux de golf de pouvoir
reprendre leur club à saint quentin dans
les yvelines le golf national l'un des
plus grands de france a rouvert ses
portes cette semaine les adhérents ont
bien entendu respecter les gestes
barrières et les équipes de tv 78
étaient présentes à l'ouverture avec
leurs meilleurs swing regardez comme le
vélo ça ne s'oublie pas mais bon les
réglages sont difficiles à 1
j'espère que je vais pas perdre trop de
balles aujourd'hui remise en route
difficile pour les golfeurs amateurs
d'autant qu'il faut maintenant composer
avec le respect des gestes-barrières
ouvert depuis le 11 mai le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à repenser
sa façon de fonctionner on peut comme
avant jouer à quatre personnes on ne
peut pas venir plus de 30 minutes avant
son heure de jeu qu'on doit
obligatoirement réserver et également on
doit
donner un sens de circulation à ce que
le maximum de clients ne se croisent pas
du tout donc on a fermé
l'accueil des clients green fille au
niveau du pro shop et on a créé ce
stacker éphémère dans le grand hall qui
s'y prête parfaitement donc les gens
rentrent du parking dans un sens et puis
ils repartent
dans un autre pour aller sur le parcours
après ils peuvent
un parent visiter le pro shops ils ont
des besoins d'achats et aussi en a mis à
disposition une seule toilette
il ya certains endroits sur le site qui
sont complètement condamné tels que les
vestiaires qui ne rouvrons pas jusqu'à
ce qu'on a le droit sur le parcours il
est dorénavant interdit de toucher vos
drapeaux ou d'utiliser un râteau plus de
bancs ou des poubelles également les
gestes barrières on y pense
obligatoirement mais on y va pour le
plaisir on fait attention aussi à ces
gestes barrières heureusement qu'on est
un sport de plein air et qu'on n'est pas
un sport où on est bien sur l'autre donc
voilà on fait partie des privilégiés qui
peut reprendre leur pratique sportive
des premiers après au golf c'est rare
qu'on est con soit l'un sur l'autre sur
le parcours on arrose plutôt à droite à
gauche donc les gestes barrières on y
pense obligatoirement lt contrainte mais
pour la direction une satisfaction
néanmoins celle de freiner les pertes
financières durant les deux mois de
confinement ce sont 20 % de perte du
chiffre d'affaires qui ont été estimées
pour revoir les professionnels foulée ce
green il faudra en revanche attendre
encore un peu l'open de france 2020
prévu en juillet ayant été annulés les
initiatives solidaires à présent dans ce
grand jt des territoires elles
fleurissent un peu partout en france
notamment en corse comme vous allez le
voir ce groupe des petites mains
solidaire justement est née après
l'appel à l'aide d'une infirmière
libérale il compte désormais pas loin de
4000 membres et avec ses amis en contact
via l'application messenger nathalie
fanfant tony a rejoint très rapidement
ce collectif situé à algajola elle
fabrique vous allez voir plusieurs
masques par jour mais également des
blues et des sur blues ce sont nos
confrères sur place de la chaîne tnt
télévisée qui l'ont rencontré regarder
lisa rinna familles ont bien aujourd'hui
du compte en faire je fais pas ça dépend
d'eux
maintenant je vais pas reliés pour faire
1 35 ans en vacances je peux aller jusqu
à châteauguay par jour
est-ce que tu expliquer les étapes de
fabrication du mas alors député mais pas
pour découper tu vois apprête à bien des
cas et quand on est enfermé mais on
forme et après il aidé à prendre donc
pas 30 repas avec les de la fille est
très pratique mais suis certainement
comme beaucoup d'autres personnes
interrogées sur mes journées sur sur ce
que je pouvais faire pour ne pas jeûner
être sincère à la fois déprimé parce que
les journées sont longues quand on sort
de ses propres habitudes de son rythme
professionnel de ses investissements au
quotidien c'était une occasion aussi de
pouvoir se sentir utile ce type de
masque la confectionnés artisanalement
on prend soin de vérifier qu'ils soient
quand même assez protecteur mais on sait
pertinemment que ces masques là ne sont
que des additions aux gestes barrière
avec les cinq personnes par messenger on
a confectionné quelques masques pour
justement le déconfinement et
principalement les personnes âgées voir
des personnes qui auraient une santé un
petit peu fragile j'ai eu quand même des
infirmières arrivé dans mon jardin
c'était une prise de conscience n'est ce
pas possible le tissu comment vous
procurer le tissu donc ce sont soit des
draveurs écrite tous à base soit c'est
du 100% coton
ça ce sont des nappes de restauration et
ensuite il ya d autres types de tissus
qui sont à la fois 50 % coton 50 ans en
polyester millions en sillage très serré
également combien de masques beauté vous
en tout temps jour ça peut être entre
eux
je dirais 15 ou 20 masques par jour
le tout c'est que les gens qui m'ont
demandé pour le onze ce soit ce soit
après voilà et dans l'actualité des
territoires est toujours concernant les
gestes de solidarité nous allons nous
rendre à reichshoffen en alsace où
plusieurs centaines de dessins vous
allez le voir sont arrivés ces derniers
jours pour les résidents de l'ehpad sur
place un vrai message d'espoir pour les
personnes âgées comme nous le montre ce
reportage de nos confrères sur place
d'assas va ce sont des messages d'espoir
qui ornent les fenêtres de l'ehpad
abrapa de reichshoffen au début de
l'épidémie de kobe 19 un appel a été
lancé par l'équipe d'animation de
l'ehpad pour recueillir des dessins
d'enfants et en quelques semaines ce
sont plusieurs centaines de courriers
qui ont fait déborder la boîte aux
lettres de l'établissement le fait
qu'ils reçoivent des dessins des textes
des lettres parfois des petites des
petits bricolages qui sont déposés qu'on
garde quelques jours pour éviter la
contamination les résidents ne se
sentent plus oublié et il voit qu'ils
sont soutenus dans cette épreuve qui est
pas toujours facile pour tout le monde
il ya même des textes et des destins qui
arrivent d'autres régions donc c'est
aller jusqu'en bretagne on a eu des gens
de bretagne de gens de corse un peu de
partout en fait
et si les dessins ont été un soutien
pour les résidents d'autres actes de
solidarité ou encourager les équipes
soignantes
au quotidien on a une liste je pense
d'une cinquantaine de donateurs qui ont
tous participé à faire en sorte en fait
que notre quotidien soit soit un peu
plus vivable est qui et qui donne le lan
fait le sourire aux soignants tu sais ce
que c'est la plus belle des choses qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse relever c'est ben
voilà la reconnaissance de notre travail
enfin à ce jour plus de 1500 dessin et
500 textes de soutien sont arrivés à
l'ehpad
voilà une jolie initiative solidaire et
pour terminer ce grand jt des
territoires une bonne nouvelle pour les
mères le site actus.fr nos partenaires
nous livre cette information sachez que
le gouvernement a donné son feu vert à
l'installation des conseils municipaux
les élus du premier tour des élections
municipales vont pouvoir siéger cette
installation aura lieu le 18 mai
prochain tous les détails sont à lire
sur le site comme vous le voyez de nos
confrères d'actu point fr voit la fin du
grand jt des territoires merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve bien sûr sur
l'ensemble des chaînes locales
régional de la tnt et sur tv5 monde au
revoir à tous et bon courage
[Musique]